le 7-8 sport sur ta vie s'il merci de
nous rejoindre chaque lundi 18h30 en
direct fait le tour de l'actualité
sportive de saint quentin en yvelines de
versailles et puis des communes
avoisinantes anthony bosso bonsoir au
programme en roller hockey course a
primé tennis de table tout d'abord oui
tout à fait on va tout d'abord
recommencer ce 7,8 sport où je recevrai
francis pons pour pour la ronde des
butineuses est aussi benjamin ferran
l'entraîneur des chocs ce d'elancourt
qui prépare les playoffs en leur hockey
le tennis de table le derby tant attendu
ce week-end locaux recevaient l'entente
de voisins saint-arnoult d'un choc avec
deux destins différents en cas de
victoire voisin s'offrait une finale
pour monter en nationale une et de ce
côté donc on pouvait assurer son
maintien récit de ce match avec des
images d'elodie moines les derniers
restent toujours des matches à part dans
une saison car ce n'est pas seulement
une victoire qui se joue mais la
domination territoriale du club cette
concurrence entre elles en cours places
fortes du tennis de table yvelinois et
voisins s'attarde où le club qui monte
au filet c'est un peu compliqué parce
qu'on a autre chose numéro 2 qui s'est
blessé
mardi donc on arrive avec une équipe
diminuée
on est un peu déçu parce que la fin du
championnat va être compliqué on on
était censé jouer la montée on peut
vraisemblablement qu'il a joués on sait
pas comment on va aborder ce match on
est resté dans la dynamique des
entraînements et des matchs qui ont de
la screen dernière le calendrier est
assez chargé en ce moment donc n'aurait
pas voilà c'est un des remises sur c'est
clair c'est même très sympa puisque
c'est la première fois qu'on va
rencontrer
saint-arnoult voisins en championnat
depuis que l'entente existe nouveau 16
octobre ce dernier a une saveur
particulière pour oran salmon et surtout
salomé la porte à la capitainerie
chinoise a frappé ses premières balles
dans les salles du palais des sports
c'est un peu étrange c'est un match
particulier où je connais plus de monde
que d'habitude mais ça me fait plaisir
de revenir jouer là c'était de deux
piliers on va dire de l'équipe de rennes
1 à l'époque qui maintenant cette équipe
là était en prob et donc elles ont
contribué on peut dire un peu à
l'histoire de cette équipe de pro b
parce qu'elle s'était de deux joueuses
importantes de l'équipe nationale 1 à
l'époque ya une dizaine d'années sur le
club de l'encours en bonne capitaine
salomé laporta oublie l'émotion du
retour sur ses terres et porte son
équipe à bout de bras dans un dernier
match elles s'imposent 3 sets à 2 face à
mme sophie jean habitué de la pro b
venus renforcer l'en cours les joueuses
vie chinoise de geoffrey nisand s'impose
finalement dix matches à six et s'offre
une finale le 20 avril face à joué les
tours en jeu l'accession à la nationale
une
et voilà pour les images de ce derby on
en avait parlé on les avait annoncés on
avait reçu les responsables des équipes
et le verdict voisin qui s'imposent
finalement ferrer et qui prend une bonne
option pour la montée en nationale une
par la suite nos invités nous ont
rejoints sur ce plateau on va parler
évidemment de la traditionnelle menant
aux rondes des butineuses qui va se
dérouler ce week-end la quatrième
édition avec francis ponge bonsoir à
vous recevoir et puis le l'objectif
majeur de l'émission aujourd'hui c'est
le roller hockey et les chocs se
d'elancourt inquiets qui prépare la
phase finale des playoffs on va en
parler évidemment avec l'entraîneur
joueur benjamin ferran bonsoir à vous
alors en tant qu'entraîneur mais aussi
joueur est ce que vous êtes satisfait de
cette saison régulière où vous finissez
troisième à la fin de la fin des
quatorze journées on a fait une belle
saison a commencé la saison un match
aller on a fait quatre victoires trois
défaites et là sur la deuxième partie de
saison les matches retour on a fait six
victoires et une seule défaite contre
les premiers donc on finit troisième à
une belle place qui me permet de
qualifier pour les play-offs d'ailleurs
je vous propose de regarder jeter un
petit coup d'oeil sur ce classement
clermont optique hamon a été juste
impérial toute la saison ils ont fini en
tête avec quasiment pas de défaite mais
voilà trente points au compteur
aubergenville 26 et et vous 24 points
aubergenville et encore c'est toujours
un peu la petite rivalité un niveau ils
vous ont ils vont devancé à la fin mai
cc c'est peut-être dû à votre coup
d'arrêt ou votre défaite assez lourde à
camon cette troisième place non je pense
qu'on aurait si on avait gagné contre
saint gratien en début de saison un
match qu'on n'aurait jamais dû perdre on
serait au dessus d'eux on serait devant
aubergenville en ce moment mais bon je
pense qu'on a fait une belle saison les
sens et c'est d'être qualifié et puis je
crois qu'au maire jean vila fait aussi
un beau parcours on peut peut-être
revoir le classement avec les
principales équipes celles qui sont
qualifiés pour ces playoffs comment vont
se passer les playoffs justement sans
les mêmes équipes que vous rencontrez
les autres poules quand il y en a en
fait
varsovie va se déplacer à besançon et on
va jouer contre
il va y avoir donné il va y avoir paré
13 elancourt et ensuite si on finit dans
les deux premiers par rapport à cette
petite poule ce petit championnat on
passera après en demi et donc dans deux
c'est à dire c'est le week-end du 20-21
ritz à l'écart après quinze jours après
les demies et peut-être peut-être qu'un
jour après les finales ont versé un
nouveau championnat qui commence à
l'organisation c'est un nouveau
championnat et justement par rapport à
cette première poule vous croyez que
c'est jouable d'accéder en demi-finale
derrière on essaie un petit peu les
équipes ou pas du tout du tout je
connais un peu les équipes je pense que
ça va être ça va être compliqué
difficile mais
je pense que vraiment pour les demi
finales on ne peut y accéder après pour
les finales je sais pas trop le niveau
va être élevé le niveau va être élevée
après va falloir savoir comment pas
comment les joueurs et l'équipe se
comporte avec un un niveau aussi élevé
quoi qu'il arrive de toute façon vous
faites mieux que la saison dernière
puisque la saison dernière vous avez
échoué aux portes des playoffs oui oui
donc pour nous c'est vraiment l'objectif
cette année c'était de se qualifier pour
les play-offs après la suite sera plus
du bougnon que du bonus et vous pensez
que l'équipe est capable de hausser son
niveau de jeu on dit toujours dès que
les playoffs débutent il faut passer au
stade au dessus là c'est un peu
l'inconnu pour vous bon je pense qu'on a
encore un bon gardien on a réussi un
on a réussi à arros aussi un nouveau
joueur qui arrive et là en tout début
janvier qui est un vrai buteur qui
s'appelle ronan que son qui a permis
d'étoffer la deuxième ligne on a trouvé
une stabilité aussi dans nos lignes donc
moi j'ai pas le cas pendant quelques
années il ya eu une période où tout se
passait très bien pour les chocs c'est
une période un peu plus difficile et là
on reconstruit vraiment un vrai groupe
et puis ça s'est reconstruit petit à
petit puisque phase aller vous avez
quatre victoires pour trois défaites ils
phase retour vous êtes à six victoires
pour une défaite donc ça montre que le
travail paie au final sur cette saison
en
est votre point fort comme vous le
disiez c'est votre gardien on a un gros
gardien et on a une grosse solidité
défensive et alors est ce que l'équipe
fanion évidemment fonctionne très bien
cette année mais c'est c'est tout un
club j'ai l'impression qu'ils
fonctionnent mieux cette année puisque
les jeunes aussi ont fait un beau
parcours en saison régulière on a permis
ben en fait à tous nos jeunes de
participer au championnat au sein d'une
entente et il y a deux équipes l'équipe
minime une équipe qui a des qui s'est
qualifié pour les play-offs avec des
joueurs d'elancourt qui qui vont
participer à ce championnat et quel va
être le mot d'ordre alors pour tous ces
joueurs qui ont joué les playoffs comme
le disait wilfried un faut toujours
essayer d'élever le niveau de jeu mais
on savait de quoi ça mon plaisir rigueur
comment comment vous allez définir tous
à l'entraînement notre niveau quand même
le but c'est déjà de se faire plaisir
mais c'est sûr que il va falloir être
bien présent aux entraînements pour tous
ces joueurs là et puis et puis qui va
hausser son niveau de jeu et se
confrontent et je pense qu'au mieux aux
meilleures équipes nationales ce1 c'est
un beau challenge dans la vie je pense
et c'est un des premiers gros
déplacement vous faites au final d'aller
à besançon comme ça sur sur cette saison
oui ça serait une expérience aussi
inédite là dessus comme le disait
wilfried away en espérant que les
joueurs sont sages au samedi soir
pourquoi ce n'est pas le cas d'habitude
au cpo somme quand on est entraîneur et
qu'on tournait alors pas permettre une
mauvaise ambiance dans le vestiaire vous
arrive policier très bien donc on suivra
ça donc le 20 et 21 avril du côté de
besançon voilà merci beaucoup mais
vraiment d'être venu sur le plateau et
puis bonne chance pour pour les playoffs
on enchaîne avec l'entente athlétique de
saint quentin en yvelines on va faire un
petit bilan de leur saison oui sur la
saison hiver en fait exactement parce
que c'est un club qui fonctionne très
bien depuis sa création début des années
2000 il s'appelle babacar diop geffray
levac ou juste une vision ils sont
montés tout sur les podiums des
championnats de france espoirs cet hiver
en en salle et ils ont un point en
commun comme vous lisiez ils sont tous
licencié à l'entente athlétique de saint
quentin en yvelines alors quelle est la
rue la recette de ce club né au début
des années 2000 éléments de réponse avec
sofival
l'entente athlétique de saint quentin en
yvelines a peut-être trouvé sa nouvelle
locomotive avec un mètre 93 pour 76 kg à
seulement 16 ans babacar diop possède un
gabarit hors du commun cet hiver il bat
le record de france du 400 mètres cadet
alors qu'il s'aligne sur le tour de
piste depuis à peine une saison c'est
dire le talent du gamin pourtant son
entraîneur philippe lefebvre la ligne
seulement sur le 200 m aux championnats
de france résultat babacar et titré et
améliore son record personnel
c'est pas si particulier mais
en même temps je reste calme parce que
c'était en salle on ne sait pas encore
ce qui se passe dans l'espace que c'est
dehors et tu penses que tu as encore une
marge de progression justement
proposeront parce que quand ces
plantages pas encore habitués avec les
lactique et en août on était en salle
c'est plus difficile pour moi déposer
mes jambes
derrière le jeune baba car tout le monde
se tire vers le haut à l'image de
jeffrey levac vice champion de france
espoirs sur le 200 m ces résultats
exceptionnels prennent leur source dans
la cohésion du groupe très travaillée à
l'entraînement avec le relais et la
mayonnaise n'est pas prêt de redescendre
c'est bon moi je les regarde je souhaite
ce à tous les entraîneurs on a vraiment
un groupe là où ils sont et qualité ils
s'entraînent dans la joie dans le
plaisir ça rigole plus qu'autre chose
mais je quitte en mieux parce que donc
on fait beaucoup de séances où on fait
du relais l'aspect collectif de l'athlé
puisse préjuger puis le bien un jour ils
m'amènent à de leurs copains et bien lui
aussi on le connaît bien et kobe tu veux
pas essayer pas filer sa i se met dedans
on a à peu près tous le même âge donc on
se suit forcément sur chaque année et
c'est vrai que depuis qu'on a à peu près
16 7 ans ont fait de bons résultats et
c'est vrai que voir les autres faire de
bons résultats ça nous pousse aussi être
commué air pur pour la suite quoi après
cette nouvelle moisson de médailles le
plus dur commence pour le meilleur club
du département garder ses pépites sur
les pistes saint-quentinoise
nous allons rester dans le domaine de la
course à pied puisque ce week-end il va
y avoir la quatrième édition de la ronde
des bétonneuses des butineuses avec un
nom très particulier d'ailleurs les
butineuses et c'est francis poncin
l'organisateur de la course qui est avec
nous pour en parler bonsoir à vous alors
déjà d'où vient ce nom puisqu'il est
quand même assez interpellant
interpelle un petit peu on est des
coureurs à pied donc en cours dans la
nature et comme notre terrain de jeu
c'est un petit peu la base de loisirs et
qu'il y a des ruches que je sais un
petit peu moi personnellement
sensibiliser au problème des abeilles on
a décidé avec la base et la ferme
pédagogique de baptiser notre course la
ronde des butineuses ça veut pas dire
que vous pourrez déguisés en abeilles il
y a 6 mai
pour ceux qui ont déjà connu des
éditions précédentes il ya des gens qui
se déguisent en abeille qui courent et
il ya un concours de déguisement avec un
trophée qui est remis par ailleurs
difficile de courir déguisés en abeilles
william a
dévoilé sa paye
impeccable et alors du coup il ya quand
même pour rester sur la course le
sportif vraiment dans les abeilles à
proprement parler il ya plusieurs
formats de course le 19 km et le 9 km
qui est très intéressant puisque à une
formule vraiment particulière aussi la
wii sur le 9 km en a lancé une formule
un peu particulière parce que c'est une
course un peu plus populaires on va dire
où on a créé un challenge et on associe
un homme une femme la parité voilà et
donc qui courent on en voit à l'écran
qui sont en train de courir attaché avec
une petite baisse de 80 cm il doit faire
tout le parcours ensemble jamais se
quitter ils doivent arriver donc
ensemble et cette distance c'est fait
aussi pour un peu popularisé donné à
tout le monde sa chance en fin de temps
en temps quand on voit par exemple le
marathon de paris qui est un peu plus
élitiste voilà le but c'est un pour nous
de permettre aux gens du secteur de
saint quentin en yvelines et plus
largement du département des yvelines de
venir courir dans un cadre agréable se
faire plaisir sur un beau parcours
autour de l'étang de saint quentin du 10
mai à la course se déroule le 14 avril
on a vu des images des éditions
précédentes c'est très beau vous
attendez à une météo peut-être plus
difficile cette fois sa taille météo
plus difficile mais aussi qu'on aura du
soleil c'est toujours comme ça donc
l'édition précédente avait lieu au mois
de mai leur serait qu' on allait
inquiéter plus agréable mais bon quand
on court a pas peur vous voulez aussi
sensibiliser un peu les participants
l'aspect environnemental en sursis alors
ça c'est un peu un effet de mode j'ai
l'impression quand même sur ses piètres
les fils de monde mais nous ça fait de
nombreuses années où on est très
pointilleux sur ce point c'est que en
cours beaucoup dans la nature et chaque
fois qu'on voit des gens à côté de nous
courir jeter des affaires et on n'est
pas très contents on est belle nature
fois ici de la respecter faut pas jeter
des bouteilles il faut pas jeter
détruite par terre on peut les ramener
tranquillement et puis bon il faut aussi
protéger l'environnement qu'on a autour
de soi est ce que c'est pas trop dur
justement d'exister parce qu'on sait que
sur le bassin de saint quentin en
yvelines il y à beaucoup de courses à
pied dans une période comme le comme le
mois d'avril où ce week-end par exemple
il y avait la guye en course le marathon
de paris est qui et qui concerne
beaucoup de coureurs saint quentinois
c'est pas trop dur d'exister si c'est
dur nous on est un tout petit club la
section course à pied dans l'expectative
lino ni vingt trois adhérents donc on
n'est pas très nombreux c'est difficile
de faire son trou quand on se frotte par
exemple à la guyane course qui est plus
de 20 ans d'existence ou parcourir
montigny
voilà où voisins c'est pas il ya des
courses qui sont rétablis depuis dix
années d année donc il faut qu'on fasse
son trou petit à petit tout doucement et
c'est une vraie concurrence étant
complémentaires hausse et complémenter
on s'entend très bien entre
organisateurs
voilà on va se voir il ya un mois
j'étais sur la grille en course je suis
allé voir des copains de voisins on se
connaît tous en fait on est tous
solidaires entre nous et le but c'est de
permettre aux gens de faire de la course
à pied de se régaler de se faire plaisir
avant tout et vous avez participé à
l'accueil en course de ce week-end non
moi je ne cours plus quelques petites
vieilles oubli sur vu l'âge qui traîne
et qui m'empêchent de courir
correctement je vais dire et pourra
attirer les participants aussi je crois
que vous leur donnez aussi l'occasion de
donner de l'argent à une association
autour de la baie on a déjà un premier
travail où on a des apiculteurs de
présents sur le site de la course avec
des dégustations de miel et des
explications par les apiculteurs et puis
depuis des années nous soutiennent
toujours d'autres associations et là on
a décidé de soutenir des amis qui
étaient venus courir l'année dernière
sur notre course dans la dame est
atteint par la sclérose en plaques
la sclérose
latérale voilà c'est il ya plusieurs
variétés c'est une dame qui faisait
beaucoup de sport haut niveau et qui
maintenant est dans une poussette et
elle le fait la course avec son mari qui
la pousse et donc on a décidé d'aider
l'association niveau local et on prélève
minimum d'un euro par participant
aussi bien sur la route des butineuses
que sur la prochaine course qu'on
organisera au mois d'octobre qui est
l'ekiden et on peut toujours s'inscrire
pour court toujours servir d'internet
puis même sur place le dimanche matin
maintenant la plupart des organisateurs
ont fait des inscriptions sur place vu
les conditions météo les gens hésitent
toujours un petit peu à venir petit
rappel des dates donc c'est ce week-end
voilà donc départ 9h30 pour le 19 km
dimanche matin et 9h40 et nevers
précisément très précises km avec une
corde si on fait donc un couple en
couple dans la ronde des butineuses
n'avons parlé aussi au début de cette
édition de roller hockey et les sharks
qui ont des portes ouvertes aussi oui on
a des portes sont ouvertes le lundi 6
mai à 14 heures au gymnase chastagner
rue paul langlois à elle encourt donc
venez nombreux pour faire participer vos
enfants au roller et au roller hockey
est d'actualité cette qualification pour
les playoffs qui vont bientôt débuter
merci à nos deux invités de cette
édition du 7 8 sport on en revient à la
course vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure
cette grille en course nous y étions oui
la 20e édition de la nuit en course ce
week-end ce courant le même jour que le
marathon de paris évidemment il y avait
un petit peu de concurrence elle se veut
d'ailleurs plus accessible que cette
épreuve si mythique que le marathon de
paris puisqu'elle est sur 10 km wilfrid
richy elodie moines vous explique tout
la 20e édition de la nuit en cours s'est
soldé dimanche 7 avril par la victoire
sur le 10 km de nicolas petitjean de le
à 50 ans en 32 minutes et 49 secondes il
termine avec plus d'une minute d'avancé
sur son principal adversaire et s'était
déjà imposé l'an dernier quelques 450
participants étaient présents sur la
ligne de départ il ya une côte vers le
6e kilomètre qui généralement
attaque plutôt bien et généralement
c'est là où on fait un peu la différence
avec les concurrents j'avais décidé en
fait d'attaquer 6e kilomètre je me suis
rendu compte
mes concurrents avaient un petit peu de
mal 24e donc c'est à partir du 4e où je
suis parti et puis j'ai réussi à
maintenir le rythme est donc je serais
content d'avoir gagné aujourd'hui un
départ en descente sur 2000 mètres avant
de négocier cette fameuse côté de
terminer sur un faux plat au stade des
droits de l'homme ce rendez vous annuel
à guyancourt se voulait tout de même
accessible au plus grand nombre à
l'opposé du marathon de paris qui se
tenait au même moment ceux qui
participent au marathon de paris se
prépare à peu près entre 6 et 8 semaines
à l'avancé et c'est pas du tout les
mêmes types de coureurs cette course et
surtout une course un peu familial c'est
à dire que tout le monde peut participer
un 10 km sans avoir un entraînement très
très intensifs
le club organisateur prépare à présent
son prochain rendez-vous le 10km
nocturne à elancourt ce sera le 1er juin
dès 20h
place d'abord au football ce week-end en
division d'honneur après leur défaite à
melun les versailles et se sont repris
en s'imposant à domicile 1 but à 0 face
à créteil lusitanos les yvelinois
remonte sur le podium de division
d'honneur par la même occasion en
promotion d'honneur trap est allé
chercher les points du match nul sur la
pelouse de saint-ouen-l'aumône un
partout et guyancourt s'est incliné
malheureusement au camp des loges face à
l'équipe 4 du paris saint-germain en
précisant c'est bien l'équipe 4 4 buts à
2 en football féminin match en retard de
la 14e journée de division 2 montigny a
frôlé l'exploit rhin ce week-end chez le
leader hénin beaumont les joueuses de
jordanie grossesse s'incline seulement
1-0 hénin beaumont est toujours invaincu
cette saison donc c'était vraiment le
challenge de ce week-end en promotion de
ligue évidemment et l'encours s'est
encore imposé 6 buts à 1 face au club
athlétique de paris les amazones ont
désormais 14 points d'avancé sur leurs
dauphines connaître la différence de
buts aussi en vrai que c'était qu'ils
aient vraiment c'est pas loin des 100
buts en 20 ans va signer pour la
prochaine édition après le football le
rugby fin du championnat de fédérale 3
oui dernière journée 18e journée de
fédérale 3 plaisir déjà qualifiés pour
les playoffs s'est incliné chez l'union
sportive pitt hiver yens 12 10 dans un
match plutôt terne ils vont pouvoir se
concentrer pleinement alors 32e de
finale le 21 avril prochain soit face à
drancy ou à rouen et puis une fois n'est
pas coutume ces trappes en basket qui
signe l'une des performances du week-end
eh oui grosse grosse performance un des
joueurs trappistes 24e journée de
national de trappes a réalisé une un
match presque parfait en fin de compte
en s'imposant face aux quatrièmes quand
80 68 chez les femmes l'entente le
chesnay-versailles termine la saison
comme elle avait débuté par une victoire
les joueuses de vinko berdych se sont
imposés de deux petits points face à
rezé 59 à 57 grâce notamment à 20 points
de virginie aurensan au classement avec
cette belle victoire 1 trappe se donne
un peu d'air les trappistes remonte à la
12e place un petit point du 11e ormes
cela se complique un peu plus pour le
maintien toutefois car les saint
quentinois devront se déplacer lors des
deux dernières journées d'ailleurs chez
maubeuge un concurrent direct pour le
maintien
des deux de l'enjeu sur sept prochaines
rencontres qui se joueront vous l'avais
dit à l'extérieur dû voler à présent oui
10e journée de pl hayden vous savez
c'est cette balle cette phase de barrage
un petit peu complexe en volleyball et
montigny s'est incliné justesse 3 sets à
2 à villejuif pourtant les signé mon
teint avait remporté les deux premiers
sets mais ils ont cédé dans un cinquième
et dernier set décisif 15 points 11 au
classement il reste tout de même
troisième de leur poule de barrage
derrière vélizy et conflans 1 qui
survole cette poule et est en bonne voie
du coup pour le maintien la
désinformation pour terminer cette
édition du 7 8 sport qui concerne le à
saint quentin oui toujours le à
saint-quentin décidément le club fait
encore une saison magnifique jean louis
henno vous souvenez où nous l'avions
reçu au début de la saison fin septembre
après son record du monde sur le 1500
mètres catégorie vétérans 4 à plus de 76
ans est bien l'athlète de l'eau à saint
quentin a rajouté quatre médailles à sa
belle collection il ya quelques semaines
aux championnats d'europe en salle titré
sur le 800 le 15 sans et le 3000 m et
avec pour le plaisir comme at il dit une
petite médaille de bronze sur le relais
4 x 200 x la cerise sur le gâteau autres
athlètes de le à saint quentin qui
ramènent deux nouvelles médailles lucide
et bénéteau oui cet athlète de la 55e'
cours pour la bonne cause pour une
association l'association pour un
sourire d'enfant qui vient en aide aux
enfants du cambodge et bien l'athlète a
tout simplement été médaillé de bronze
aux derniers 800 mètres aux championnats
d'europe du côté de san sebastien merci
anthony pour cette édition du 7 8 fort
on retrouve lundi prochain pour un
nouveau point complet oui d'ailleurs
n'hésitez pas à le commenter un soc 7 8
sport sur les réseaux sociaux et avec le
hashtag le 7-8 sport tout attaché et
nous donner tous les résultats de vos
clubs évidemment à lundi prochain bonne
soirée